okay I've been accused of many things on
the show everything from being a cuck to
being a Jew conspiracist and lots of
other stuff but I've never been accused
of triggering the downfall of the United
States of America the third-world status
but that's exactly what this caller
claims I'm participating in take a
listen to this voice mail came across
your program on flipping channels and
you know what you when people like you
are the reason why the culture of this
country has been a diluted and I say in
mmm two three four generations we will
be a third world country because of
left-wing extremists and we will be
socialist society decides yeah I'm not a
socialist look I don't know what this
guy's talking about but in some kind of
weird way it's flattering to think that
the program has so much power that we
could even affect this degree of change
at the top of the show I was talking
about sort of the feelings of futility
in the Trump era about how much change
we can actually accomplish not that I
would want to make the United States a
third world socialist country I've never
expressed that and I don't I don't think
I have that power but the idea that
someone thinks I might have that power
is actually kind of flattering in some
way we want this guy to just continue
flipping channels we want him to tune in
I don't know listen I I'm not gonna turn
away any audience member but try to
understand what the program is if you're
gonna comment on it we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the evolution of so-called magic
mushrooms
how many did Pat have in his vegan
burger last night hopefully he will tell
us on the bonus show we will also talk
about a lawsuit from Satanists and Ben
Carson's interesting furniture habits
I'll leave it there get access to the
bonus show at david pakman.com slash
membership also by being a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show